there's no we're invisible there's no
competition you have to get used to it
get a strong competitor and you will
grow faster than you ever believed that
you could
I've always just really enjoyed just the
competition of business
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up live nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message don't worry about
the competition over to you Jack Ma also
if you want to know a Jack and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confident series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
the people who did the bottom should
believe in the model and I believe what
I do when you do business
don't worry about competition there's
nowhere in this world there's no
competition you have to get used to it
you cannot stop globalization the world
is getting so small
if you cannot stop it improve it at the
competition today it's like a ten
thousand meters running
for the first 200 meters don't think
that guy is the competitor keep on
running 3,000 meters later you will know
who is the competitor I think
competition is great I think competition
makes you stronger I think without
competition you get lazy slow lethargic
and complacent the Yankees had the Red
Sox Tupac had biggie Frazier had Ali the
dogs have the postman people will do
more to avoid paint and to gain pleasure
your pleasure is your mission your pain
is your competition beating you get a
strong competitor and you will grow
faster than you ever believed that you
could so I look at the growth of this
YouTube channel as an example when I
first started on my agency and started
taking this seriously I asked my agent
who is the number one guy your agency
and they gave me a name and this guy was
way ahead of me at the time on YouTube
and I thought I'm gonna beat that guy I
told him I told me I did I'm gonna be
ahead of that guy at the agency and that
became my goal you know I was on my
mission to help entrepreneurs but I
wanted to beat this guy and that guy
made me better make me stronger pushed
me every day to improve my content even
though at the time he had no idea who I
was
I saw his page I wanted to get better I
wanted to improve and he pushed me
forward
now I ultimately blew past that guy and
then it became about beating Gary Vee so
it was me and Gary Vee who at the top of
the industry and last year I had a
mental game for myself that I want to
beat Gary Vee to a million subscribers
my goal was I want to beat Gary B to 1
million now Gary knows me we've collabed
on some stuff but he didn't care who hit
a million first I didn't tell him about
my goals my own internal metric like I
wanted to be Gary to a million and then
when's the summer came around August
came around I remember making a video on
my stream saying I hope Gary doesn't
mail it in this time I hope he doesn't
just give it to his team because every
August he goes away he gives it to his
team and his numbers go down and I
wanted the competition
we were neck-and-neck and then in
august-september I blew past him because
again he gave it to his team he wasn't
producing original content and his
channel suffered and then I beat him to
a million subscribers and I felt I felt
like a loss because it was too easy
because we were neck-and-neck and it was
too easy and I felt a letdown I wanted
the competition even though he didn't
care he pushed me forward and now Gary's
passed me again and so it's amazing
right like now I got I gotta chase him
down again I gotta beat him again and
yes it's all about the mission it's not
just beating Gary Gary and I our friends
I love him i watch his videos I love
what he stands for I love most of what
he's putting out and this is friendly
rivalry that he may not even care about
but I love it and I want to beat him and
I want to get past him again
I look at my Instagram strategy I'm just
starting from nothing on Instagram
beginning this year I had 6,000
followers on Instagram and we're sitting
at 70,000 Plus now I'm trying to hit a
hundred thousand by the end of the year
we'll see if that happens and I'm
chasing down the people ahead of me
again it's amazing cuz I'm the worst
right like 6,000 followers compared to
1.6 million on YouTube and I'm looking
at everybody who's ahead of me and like
I get to do the climb all over again
cuz on YouTube it's only Gary that's
bigger than me an Instagram there's lots
of people I'm thinking of even starting
a series called chasing the sharks where
I look at all the shark tank people the
advisers that the investors and doing a
update of like me chasing them down and
it's not just about beating them because
I wouldn't do anything at all costs to
beat them I'm not taking out advertising
or not I'm not spamming people I'm not
I'm not doing anything at all costs I
still want to pursue my mission I still
need to do things the right way I still
need to produce amazing content it's
still all about believe that's the
positive side of it but I want to beat
them and I like the chase I like the
competition they make me stronger they
make me push harder I think it's very
healthy to have somebody in your
industry who can challenge you can push
you stronger to go off and chase your
goals down and if you're the best in
your industry that's when that's when
monopolies happen that's when companies
start to tank and so if you are already
the best then you need to widen your
circle to find somebody else who you can
compete against and say they're not
exactly my industry but they're close
enough and I want to tackle them too now
this does not mean that
you have to copy what they're doing this
doesn't mean that you only are doing the
same thing they're doing I mean I love
looking like Gary's Channel I love
looking at other people's IG content
ISIL did do me you still need to do you
it's not about looking at the
competitors getting worried and copying
their features and bringing it over to
what you're doing you can't just be a
junior version of somebody else it's the
inspiration it's seen people grow if
you're in an environment of people who
are hustling and doing well and you feel
like you're not pushing as hard it'll
push you a little bit faster when you're
running the race and the guy next to you
or the girl next to you is catching up
or is just a little bit ahead of you
it'll give you the push to run a little
bit faster and that's the point if you
are far front or even really far back to
if there's nobody like close to you then
you won't push as hard if you're dead
last by a mile you're not gonna push as
hard because you know you're last if
you're way ahead by a mile you're not
gonna push as hard because the
competition's not next to you but if
there's somebody right there somebody
right there who's just a little bit
ahead of you or who's catching up to you
it's going to help you find that extra
little degree of effort of patience of
frustration to push into powerfully
making action happen in your business so
I'm gonna give you three ways and how to
find competition and use it to motivate
you in a healthy way on a daily basis
step number one is find one two three
close rivals find one two three close
rivals who you are running they're like
they're right next to you they're a
little bit ahead of you they're a little
bit behind you your jockey for position
but they're running the race with you
and I want to try and define some kind
of metric that we can track so for me
I'm looking at YouTube subscribers I'm
looking at Instagram followers in your
industry what is it that you're paying
attention to is that winning awards is
it revenue is it employees what is it
that you're gonna attract but somebody
who's like who's right there next to you
pick one two three one two three close
rivals that you feel you're kind of
neck-and-neck with and you want to beat
them step number two is pick one two
three aspirational rivals these may be
people who you may never ever catch but
like you want to play in that game you
want to be up there you're running with
these three people now from step one but
you want to be running up there you want
to be running the bigger game you want
to be running into bigger races who are
those people that you want to track down
I look at me on youtube and
right now there's there's nobody from an
aspiration lament or so I might need to
expand my basis say okay kind of
conquered the entrepreneur space it's me
and Gary we're rivals are running next
and next to each other but am I gonna
chase down pewdiepie I'm gonna chase
down Logan Paul like who's the next
person I can get amped up for an
Instagram it's a lot easier because I
look at me having 70,000 followers and
Gary having 4.5 million or whatever he's
at now it seems like such a far gap it
seems like it's gonna be impossible to
close but I love it right I want to have
those eyes I want to be running up in
those fields I want to be running in
that race I want to be in that category
and so I've got my 1 2 3 who are with me
now and then I got the my 1 2 3 who are
way out there I think it's really
helpful to follow them and feel like I
want to be in that game I want to be in
that game I want to play at that level
that's where I belong that's why I
belong up there up there up there have
those one of three aspirational mentors
as well and in September 3 is look at
your progress daily look at your
progress daily to see how are you
competing so for me I have a tab in my
chrome that I look at every day of 20
ish websites on a daily basis that I'm
tracking and two of the websites track
me versus my competition on YouTube and
on Instagram I use social blade they
have an awesome tool called favorites
and I could track how I compete versus
where my competition is and I know
here's what I gained yesterday here's
what I gained so far today here's how
I'm gaining in the past 90 days his farm
game and it gives me the stats it gives
me the updates that I know I'm getting
better I'm getting better tasting it oh
man Gary's pulling ahead what's he doing
Gary spa I gotta pick up my game let's
go let's go let's go and so having that
daily tracking for both categories so
the people who are right next to you aim
for the people who are way ahead of you
every single day checking those numbers
not not obsessing about it and checking
it 25 times a day because that's not
gonna help but just as a quick
motivational boost to remind you of the
race that you're running to remind you
of who you're up against right now to
remind you the mission that you're on
and to remind you of where you feel like
you belong to remind you where you
should be further ahead on a daily every
single day basis because it's easy to
get motivated one day and then the next
thing you wake up
and the motivations gone so you start
from scratch every day and reminding
yourself that this is where I'm at
here's who I'm running here's my running
mates and that's where I want to be that
that race up there that's where I belong
I'm gonna go chase that down on a daily
basis gives you so much Drive so much
power so much momentum so step number
one pick one two three close rivals step
number two pick one two three
aspirational rivals and step number
three find a way to track your progress
lately now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know who is one
aspirational rival that is pushing you
forward let me know put it in the
comments below
I've always just really enjoyed just the
competition of business I think you know
in in the sports business
I'll talk to our players and it'll be
like well you guys can people 48 minutes
and you practice a couple hours and you
work on your game independently a couple
hours but the ultimate sport is business
because you have to compete with
everybody and you have to do it 24 by 7
by 365 days a year forever and there's
always somebody out there trying to kick
your butt there's always somebody who
looks at your business and says I can do
that better I have a better idea
and you're you have to compete with that
person and all the while you have to
make your customers happy your employees
happy it's it's the competitive side of
me that in any entrepreneur that I think
that that has to drive you and and I
think that carries over into the
Mavericks I want to win and I want to
compete you don't want to live in a
world where there's only one voice you
want to be able to say you know what I
know that this newspaper its editorial
page leans this way and I know that this
newspapers editorial page leans the
other way am i more comfortable reading
the editorial page that justifies
bolsters and enforces the way I feel
yeah of course they say that editorial
page is smart but a really smart person
will say now I'm gonna take a look at
what at what the competition has to say
because that makes you smart you see
because sometimes you can take away from
the competition I mean the competition
competitions in business like it's not
as if there's only one reader of the
competition we're speaking you know
we're speaking in soft terms right now
but isn't that when there's not only one
person reading that newspaper that
newspapers is supported by enough people
so that it would seem to me if you're
reading one editorial page you want to
look at the other and say you know what
there were reason that people are
reading that editorial page maybe
there's something there that I'm missing
so you want both sides and if you don't
have reasoned debate then you're a one
sided fool competitive if I tell Jim
from cousins Maine lobster I'll have his
picture but you know I talked about him
before if I tell him one little thing
about the guy he used to compete with on
the hockey team Jim was a semi
professional hockey player had some
injury or something in the minor leagues
if I'm tell him that right but anyway
his archenemy on the other team was a
guy named Luke what do you think
happened Luke's for me Jim's from Maine
Luke went into the lobster business all
I have to do to double sales say hey Jay
here Luke opened another restaurant talk
about competitive spirit he's ready to
kill he doesn't stop working he hates
the idea that somebody might beat him at
a game
it says DNA and his partner savings the
same way all I have to do is tell Grace
& Lace who makes beautiful lacy socks
and shawls and my most successful
business by far in terms of making money
and what do I have to do to get them
going hardly anything all I got to do is
that God got a big check from a cousin's
today you know I'd get a check from her
like within the week a bigger check
they're winning we're more successful
why I just said compete with Merlin
that's the way they weren't competitive
you get an entrepreneur who doesn't feel
the heat of competition he's not gonna
be good on his feet she's not gonna come
to the fore when she really needs it
that competitive spirit drives you
through all the things that don't make
any common sense in life I do not have a
rich father not from you know
well-educated I said I tried three times
for University all filled for the last
time I went to the teacher's college
which was considered the third or fourth
class of my city